[Applaudissements]
salut comment ça va bien vous êtes tout
là qu'on accepte de faire chaque fils la
6e quelqu'un qui répond pas à cette
question là en disant qu'il le fait pour
ses concitoyens qu'il le fait en pensant
à ces enfants une place mais est ce que
tu vas te vient bientôt parce que y est
7 heures 30 puis l'école commence
bientôt aux meubles
bon comme on avait assisté cugnaux la
réparation vous ans j'ai toujours dit
c'est juste d'avoir avec l'équipe qu'il
soit ça marche tout petit il soit ça
fait une chance ce paysage vous dire que
2 jours 1 nous on agit sur la question
de vannes comment ça s'est passé car
quand on vous en a mobilisé un épisode
un peu surréel dans une chambre d'hôtel
mystère et ibos vous rencontrez premier
bizkit annonce lors qu'elles seront
faits des fonctions
la vérificatrice générale oui a indiqué
communiste des transports vient
climatique une lourdeur administrative
et les processus sont complexes
comment vous entendez vous y prendre
pour faire le ménage moi je me considère
chanceux un certain point mon
prédécesseur a commencé à faire ce
ménage là c'est le prends comme mission
personnelle de redonner confiance aux
québécois dans l'histoire de france mais
qu'est ce qui s'en vient pour vous
pourrez ajouter l'oeuf d'amaya un caucus
des députés
hannover ensuite période des questions à
10 heures ensuite je suis de garde
je garde d'après midi où entreront
heures et 13 heures 4 heures jean comité
top teams mystérieux
puis après ça vers 15 heures le retour
en outaouais et on se lève tous les
matins à 4h pour la d3 le pilote est
féminisé transport pinault dit silva
serait lié au consensus effet conçu la
voie réservée le député essaie de me
vendre doucy auquel je suis déjà fendu
madame la présidente
[Musique]
la première question on le peaufine et
je m'attendais pas à voir une question
sur une autoroute particulière comme
comme première question mais bon ça
s'est bien passé je pense tout le monde
est nerveux avant première question et
255 se faisait qu'on devrait être une
nouvelle
8 heures
vous avez maintenant un garde du corps
qui agit aussi comme chauffeur donc
votre quotidien dans le trafic ne sera
plus jamais le même vous avez vous serez
plus vraiment derrière le voile à la et
steve le sait pas encore mais je pense
que déjà on a des seins des plans pour
prendre le transport en commun une fois
de temps en temps juste pour pour
comprendre la réalité des gens je pense
qu'on a aussi une mentalité peut-être
changé au ministère des transports de
toujours penser à l'utilisateur avant
qui que ce soit d'autre